ينضموا الينا من دير البلح مراسل الجزيره
اشرف ابو عمره اشرف الاحتلال استهدف منزلا
في منطقه دير البلح اطلعنا اكثر على
التفاصيل نعم هذا المنزل في منطقه حكر
الجامه حيث جنوب مدينه دير البلح كان عدد
كبير من المواطنين يقطنون داخل منزل عائله
ابو صفر بالقرب من حي كبير وواسع يقطنه
الالاف من المواطنين ولكن هذا المنزل
استهدفته الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
بصواريخ بشكل مباشر وبدون سابق انذار هذا
الامر ادى الى ارتقاء اثنين من الشهداء
وبالاضافه الى ذلك عدد كبير من المصابين
جلهم من الاطفال والنساء والكبار في السن
وصلوا هنا مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح هذه الغاره ليس الغاره الاولى على
دير البلح سبقها غاره اخرى على منزل عائله
ابو نصير والتي ما زالت الطواقم وبادوات
بسيطه جدا تحاول الوصول لعشره من
المفقودين داخل وتحت ت انقاذ منزل عائله
ابو نصير ايضا شرق مدينه دير البلح
الغارات الاسرائيليه تتزايد في الساعات
الماضيه على المحافظه الوسطى حيث في
المخيم الجديد في مخيم النصرات اغارت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه على عدد من
منازل المواطنين هذا الامر ادى الى وقوع
ايضا اصابات وشهداء وصلوا مستشفى العوده
بمخيم النصرات المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ايضا
تواصل عمليه اطلاق قذائفها باتجاه المناطق
الشرقيه لمخيم المغازي بالاضافه الى منطقه
المصدر الى الشمال من مدينه دير البلح
المستشفى هنا مستشفى الشهداء الاقصى وصل
خلال الساعات الماضيه وبحسب اداره
المستشفى اكثر من 10 شهداء بالاضافه الى
عشرات المصابين الذي ما زال عدد منهم داخل
المستشفى يتلقى العلاج اذا ما تطرقنا
للوضع الانساني ايضا المتفاقم في المحافظه
الوسطى وخاصه في مدينه دير البلح والتي
تاوي اعداد كبيره من النازحين وايضا هنا
داخل مستشفى شهداء الاقصى اداره المستشفى
تتحدث عن ا عن وضع ضع انساني صعب للغايه
داخل المستشفى مع تكدس اعداد كبيره من
المصابين والجرحى والمرضى في ممرات
المستشفى وفي ازقه المستشفى اضطرت اداره
المستشفى الى انشاء بعض الخيام في الساحات
الخارجيه للمستشفى لوضع الجرحى والمرضى
بداخلهم بالاضافه الى ايضا الوضع الانسان
المتفاقم داخل مراكز الايواء في مدارس
الاونروا او ايضا في مخيمات النزوح التي
تم انشاؤها في مدينه دير بلح في هذه
الاجواء البارده الاجواء الشتويه
والمنخفضات التي تاتي ما بين اليوم والاخر
على المحافظه الوسطى وعلى قطاع غزه بشكل
كامل شكرا لك
مراسلنا اشرف ابو عمره حدثنا من دير
البلح